Hello! Welcome to Michael's Better Business English.
This month, we're looking at how to make polite requests.
Here, there are two key areas: culture and language.
First, culture.
Often, Japanese business people prefer this indirect style;...
...giving hints, rather than speaking directly.
However, be careful.
In western business culture, we prefer to make direct requests;...
...clear and easy to understand.
Of course though, you must use polite English.
Here, there are three levels of polite English for requesting.
First one, respectful.
Respectful is for clients, customers or senior members of your company.
Here, we often use expressions like, "Would you," or "May I do something?"
Second level, businesslike.
This is more commonly used with co-workers or people you often work with.
Here, we often use expressions like, "Could you," or "Can you?"
For example, "Could you reschedule the meeting to the 10th?"
Finally, the last level, casual.
This should be used with close friends and family.
Here, we often use expressions like, "Will you?"
For example, "Will you close the door?"
Do be careful with this expression though.
This can sound a little bit angry...
...with the feeling, "Why haven't you done this earlier?"
For example, "Will you send me the report?"...
...might feel like "Why haven't you sent me the report already?"
So, only use this with close friends and family.
So, use this advice to make polite requests.
Thank you and good luck!